how's it gonna back my name is beautiful
welcome to Scribblenauts unlimited and
we're in the second last area right now
we unlocked a new one and it's like a
storybook fairy tale whatever
I'm here with horsey having one iron
shed which is pretty badass but I feel
like horse is missing something
hold on much better alright let's start
this quest help Hansel and Gretel
survive this harrowing tale what you
don't like my dad says you don't like it
because you're jelly we don't like it
you cut it okay Hansel and Gretel are at
exploring give them something to leave a
trail behind them what am i wet what is
going on here what the [ __ ]
alright [ __ ] bread beard take the
beard
does that help bread for [ __ ] sake not
hey go I think that's how this story
goes done know hopefully [ __ ] how is
that a solution why did you eat the
bread alright what's next our trail is
gone that's why do they need a trail
from Rock from here to there alright
they need something else bread oh the
bread doesn't work there I get it well
they trick you they trick you those
bastards
I brought a thread not the [ __ ] music
but stop eating the bread take the
thread woman
take the [ __ ] credits right here by
right about gnome tower I always wanted
to have a rideable gnome tower okay what
do you want
maybe stones for [ __ ] sake stones
scone stop I love scones it's so good
you go [ __ ] me
scones for breakfast with cream and
marmalade Oh help the old woman cut some
firewood and taken in the stone I
suspect this old woman is not who she
says she is except old I guess I don't
know all right
firewood Jason there you go she wants to
burn them makeup all right I guess we
need to just type it
wow that was it that was that Jay says
you guys are stupid not you you're
beautiful I meant those duster in the
game oh that's your hat name is Hansel
and grater and you're watching this
video all right what's going on what do
you want now
once it's cut don't forget to bring it
to the stove do I have to do it as well
but they just Wow you found my trap oh
no I'm so surprised by this will serve
as my slave and house it will become my
dinner that sounds pretty good I would
love to eat Hansel sorry we're gonna
have some dinner
give Hanson something to fool the witch
into not eating him I don't remember
this story kara my plump and delicious
looks what what can I do to make this
witch not eat me how about I make you
into chocolate it's not how the story
goes harmless baby Yaya what the [ __ ]
and developing pizza oven pizza oven I
need to learn the rich over here so I
can say my brother how about a witch
Lerner
I wish Euler
[Music]
how does how does this work what the
[ __ ] is going on right now now it's your
chance
what okay she died we [ __ ] killed her
this game is great for kids
the evil hag is no more time to rescue
an something get out of here
I'll take this kick it's pretty hot
though this is so crazy I don't even
know what the [ __ ] what is she doing now
alright see you in May garden Oh run
home chillin thank you so much for
keeping them safe have this what why is
it that it is alright let me pick that
up
ah [ __ ] Hansel and Gretel day are
complete 41 star rights [ __ ] dead I
did the dirt
alright let me take this Baron I shed
your weight this law rocket what my face
became a rocket well you're awesome I
love you alright what do you want what
do you want my nose it grows from all my
life if I'm honest can you restore it to
its size how about a plastic surgeon
oh I spell that right I can't believe
this is working just rock it bear away
what happens up here friends my rat's
have gotten out of control I need
something that's musical how about you
bear you're pretty musical aren't you
yeah a [ __ ] worked all right cool
what's up my love for her just leaves me
sobbing I wish we had more things in
common well how about we make her
[ __ ] here I mean just really big real
big
you can now have sex without feeling
awkward what about you I have to talk
but by charged shagging I need some help
blowing the pig's house in
well how about you bear can you do it
bear is unable it's only musical love
spreading how about a huge wind blower
wind drover whoa what the [ __ ] is that
not actually work
sorry little pigs all that poor little
pig it died dead edit whoa
welcome to volcana thank you thank you
so much what happens in the volcano
stays in the volcano what whop whop whop
whop whop i'm pierre - sky
what do you want this guy looks high as
[ __ ] give him something so you can play
fetch with a dog ball I don't [ __ ]
know Jesus nice throw bro nice throw
that seems like a fun game I love this
jazzy music oh no no no no [ __ ] that was
a close one
what do you want I forgot what I was its
Frodo Frodo you stupid son-of-a-bitch
let's throw him in a ring we're
wandering Carolla my throw away yeah
[Music]
and the Eagles awesome reference also
alright
help save the village from a volcano
that's alright I can do that press well
Cain a sacrifice start hey I like I'm
wearing the Hat it's going to a wrap
alright we're gonna have to throw stuff
in the volcano
it's alright we have to sacrifice Justin
Bieber go Justin me though I have to
sacrifice Lady Gaga Lady got to go head
wax we have to sacrifice him search
sorry I'm sorry
edge worked
the devil is satisfied volcana still
angry maybe some happy with our
dependency on technology try to appease
it by writing more sacrifices oh [ __ ]
a TV oh no not my chain a anything about
my television more what hell do you want
a phone [ __ ] I don't know it doesn't
look like it's working at all I don't
even know why we're doing this okay what
else what else bad pewdiepie no we can't
sacrifice Peter by but I love teddy pie
ah
rest in peace pizza pie give them a key
no donation money then what Kenny wants
money that greedy son of a [ __ ] volcano
good oh [ __ ] it's still angry why does
it sound like popcorn
[Music]
now the volcano goddess has appeared and
it's demanding a love interest right a
mate that she will be happy with Philip
I take the sediment flying Jesus flying
alpha male
hey go wow she's happy with an alien
mayor well that is nasty
what take that [ __ ] up mmm well Kane a
sacrifice completed 44 it will need six
more breaths awesome good job good job
Rach good job good job
that's going on that one yeah bro what's
up what's up bro help me temper with
this magic sword how about we turn it
into a laser sword
much better what I don't know what I did
awesome
cool go inside chicken shoot that is so
lame
you suck chicken alright what is these
people who want white I missed something
what is this provide the spark of life
magic yes
No ah hell with that what are you guys
want free us from the cockatrice
petrifying gaze that is a petrifying
gaze alright
Maria Wanda what the [ __ ] is a cocker at
church I want to [ __ ] our chess it sucks
how did that work I have a cockatrice
shut up huh oh I crown thank you
invisible how's that invincible I can
totally see it what are you talking
about
what does he one micron is lost in this
volcano please return it to me
alright pick up oh no now no none my
[ __ ] at reg make it rain
I have to put it's like Indiana Jones
all right a crown I have to put this
here now stop taking it up no I might
cry I got nothing I'm gonna die
all right caca trench as much as I love
you
not you [ __ ] you nearly killed what the
[ __ ] are you doing cartridge stop out
[ __ ] a trench
I know you oh there you go is that a
[ __ ] worth it
my cockatrice is an [ __ ] yeah ha
indeed you know what are you doing in my
[ __ ] what are you what are you doing
shut up
all right we earned another bit whoa why
is everything turning into stone is it
because of this caca trench perhaps all
right pres hope you enjoyed this episode
like a barrack top I die okok all right
I and I'll see you next episode I'm a
mommy
[Music]